if you look at all the information we've
been able to gather so far it is a
natural step forward that you would have
to go to an impeachment inquiry that
provides Congress the Apex of legal
power to get all the information they
need you've got to get to be able to
answer that to the American public the
American public deserves that answer
interesting words there from the house
Speaker the White House they might
finally be realizing the threat of
impeachment is real NBC reporting that
the administration set up a war room of
two dozen lawyers legislative aides and
communication staffers to lead a quote
aggressive response joining us now is
Jonathan Turley professor of law at
George Washington University and a Fox
News contributor and one of the most
brilliant analysts I think we have here
at Fox News it's an honor to have you
Jonathan Turley
thank you I mean it Jonathan for all of
that I mean that a lot but this um this
war room which is conventional you know
Trump had one he had a team that you
know put out PR and you respond to an
impeachment inquiry so that's not
abnormal but what is interesting to me
here is the Biden War Room want to model
themselves after the Clinton 1998
impeachment model and they say Biden
officials believe they are even better
positioned to win the Battle of public
opinion than Clinton what do you think
well you know the problem is that
they're establishing this war room
before a war they could easily avoid an
impeachment inquiry by simply asking the
the National Archives to release this
information for the president to release
information from his own Financial
accounts and that would really forestall
the need to have an inquiry it's only
because they have been stonewalling that
Congress has very little choice in my
view but to move forward I mean consider
what Congress has right now I mean even
the media is now accepting that there
has been an influence peddling operation
conducted by Hunter Biden by his uncle
and by others worth tens of millions of
dollars from foreign sources The
Washington Post recently admitted that
the president has been lying about his
son's business dealings in China uh
Devin Archer an associate of Hunter said
that it was patently false what the
president's been telling them public for
years that he had no knowledge of their
business dealings so what is Congress
supposed to do now if they go to an
impeachment inquiry they're going to win
they go to court and and and demand
these emails demand the financial
records are going to win the Democrats
went to court to insist on Trump's
banking records so the question I have
again is why set up a war room if you
don't have to have a war you know why
not be transparent if all these emails
are trivialities then have them released
and put it to to rest but right now
we've got 20 million dollars or more
passing through a Labyrinth of accounts
and shell corporations to Biden family
members the president benefits from that
right he's he's a person that is worth
more than eight million dollars the
people at his age are usually trying to
create Financial legacies for their
family they're not trying to gather more
money in their person accounts that's a
benefit but we also don't know if the
president has gotten direct benefits the
Democrats are now arguing okay look
there was influence peddling but it was
an illusion how do you know that I mean
the obligation of Congress is to find
answers to those questions
yeah and Professor Turley I only have a
few moments here but the impeachment in
Corey as I understand it which McCarthy
made News Today by suggesting he would
allow a vote for the impeachment inquiry
contrast that to Pelosi who just by
proclamation said impeachment inquiry
begin that would allow Congress to have
expanded powers to gain access to some
of those records is that right
that's right and I've spoken to the
speaker and other members and they're
going about this right they're not
repeating the mistakes of the Democrats
an impeachment inquiry does not mean an
impeachment's inevitable but it means
the house is going to go forward until
they get answers to these questions
Professor Turley thank you very much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else